where are we now is uh
enabling village it is situated in bukit
mera it used to be a taxi driving center
and now it is repurposed and we use as a
ability village and it is of course it's
an inclusive garden
for everyone we are trying to introduce
a corn system
the flow through the whole garden
without any
mechanical filtration system so
everything
that you see here the plants are
interacting with
all the non-living materials like wind
soil
or water so the water here is cleansed
and the soil is fertilized through leaf
litter
and nitrogen is fixed into the ground
through
legume that we introduce so it is very
much
of a natural system happening here and
it's a self-sustainable
system i think the perception of humans
and nature has changed over the time
from really cement the nature
far away from human because we need to
tendon
until now we started to accept the
nature being
part of our living compound i think that
is very important because we started to
accept other living babies
with us in 2015 we moved
our office from the cbd area tanjung
baga to
where we are now in perth city and we
are at the seventh floor
and we got this very expensive step six
that looked down into the old horse
range area
so then we started to collect plants
and at that time we were thinking okay
it's time for us to bring back
the knowledge that we have from a
rainforest into the city
in our sky garden at the seventh floor
of grandstand
we do collect about 400 species of
plants
and meanwhile we rewild it with fauna
we do release stick insects and four
line tree frogs they are very curious
occasionally there are some birds that
flew in and built their nests and we let
it grow
and study how the plants react to all
this nature that come out from outside
we are doing a lot of greening of high
rise skyscraper
and we have this interest to know more
about how can we bring up
more ecosystems up to the sky instead of
all on the ground
how can we give different character to
the skyscraper
we started to talk about rewilding not
only on the ground
but into the sky and into revolving the
mind
for the 20 to 50 years in singapore we
hope for
a change in bioethics because singapore
has been very successful on the
biophilia city
and people start to realize there are
other living beings around them
we hope the gap between human and nature
can be weaved through
in the next 20 to 50 years maybe because
it will be a long battle